first off I'm gonna make a really nice
light Carol pan on nice and low great to
apples and this helps to almost sort of
purely apples so much quicker a lot of
flavoring the skin so don't worry about
peeling the fruit whether it's pears
plums peaches the flavors in the skin
nice start the camera a couple of
tablespoons of sugar there sugar helps
to get rid of the tartness in the apple
a touch of cinnamon that starts to
making it a little spicy open up your
vanilla just scrape out all those seeds
now this just makes it light and
fragrant all those seeds in the sugar
we're making caramel be patient and
always swirl the dish instead of
stirring it when the sugar goes Brown
add the apple
that starts to sort of cool down the
cattle but it gives it a really nice
sort of caramelized pureed apples almost
disintegrating smells incredible
tell me guess now slice up two apples
it's the crumble that's got no frills
straightforward there faffing around I'm
peeling of the skin I want them to sort
of stand out from the camera apples in
now there's nice thick chunks of Apple
sort of almost betting yourself into the
puree dried cranberries gives it that
nice sort of shock in the texture sweet
and chewy I want it to sort of taste
zesty spicy so set the lemon zest on top
of your apples and cranberry fresh lemon
juice over and that just gives that
extra acidic kick takes the cranberries
the apples the camel and the cinnamon to
another level turn the gas off just let
that sit and let's concentrate on the
crumbled flour in I cut the tablespoons
of Demerara sugar sugar helps to get the
topping nice and crispy
butter in give that a nice little
filling rub looking for is like a
breadcrumb mixture lightly seasoned it
with a touch of cinnamon and the
Demerara sugar sort of helps to get a
nice fine crumble mix and it stops the
butter I'm sort of melting in that flour
so that's the basic crumble mix but I'm
not finished yet
music two-thirds crumble one-third
muesli mix that in if you haven't got
muesli and crunchy granola works
brilliantly - lovely now start off in
the center and work your way around
I want the crispness on the top the pure
on the bottom with a camel and then a
texture in the center a good tip
turn the gas back on want it bubbling
before he goes in the oven because then
you've just got to cook the top so as
soon as you see that camera start the
bubble down the side in she goes let's
go bake at 200 degrees Celsius for 12 to
14 minutes until golden brown smells
amazing
[Music]
beautiful still bubbling and look at it
a delicious but very simple crumble with
apples at the absolute best beautiful
[Music]
nice long strokes so we get the whole of
the blade beautiful pierce that open
squeeze it in that delicious